cette proposition de loi elle est issue
elle émane du terrain en fait d'une
longue expérience dans ma profession de
médecin généraliste voyons effectivement
quelques fois des situations compliquées
d'étudiants dans les parents sont
handicapés ou un des deux parents étant
handicapés avec tous les soucis que ça
comportent c'est-à-dire à la fois des
soucis financiers des soucis de
logistique des soucis quelquefois
psychiques aussi parce que ça n'est pas
facile d'avoir l'esprit à la fois sur
ses études et quelque part aussi dans
l'accompagnement de son parenté et je
suis vraiment très heureux que ce soit
voté à l'unanimité c'est pas tous les
jours donc profitons de ça c'est
important pour les étudiants
qui vont pouvoir bénéficier d'une bourse
je dirais d'un accompagnement social
reconnaissant reconnaissant leur statut
d'aidant enfin parce qu'ils étaient
jusque là invisibles
[Musique]
le cap que j'ai fixé a été plus ouvert
encore par la commission permettant aux
étudiants bien sûr d'avoir une aide
financière et c'est important ça a été
évoqué le cas du déménagement ne
serait-ce que pour se nourrir ou se
loger le plus c'est que aujourd'hui la
ministre ouvre vers le fait que au-delà
de ça a été demandé par la commission au
delà de l'aide financière il y a aussi
peut-être un accompagnement
complémentaire à la fois dans
l'aménagement du programme d'étudiants
mais aussi peut-être dans une aide
personnalisée et je crois que ça c'est
vraiment important et je suis satisfait
en fait d'avoir ouvert la voie à cette à
cette dimension autre qu'a donné la
Commission et la ministre en approuvant
ce texte
[Musique]